in this video I want to talk about the
TCA cycle or otherwise known as the
Krebs cycle or the citric acid cycle and
basically just give a short introduction
to it well what is the purpose of the
TCA cycle basically it's to make a bunch
of nadh and fadh2 if you recall nadh is
the reduced form of nad plus and fadh2
is the reduced form of f8d so both of
these are carrying electrons and that is
basically the that's stored energy
that's reduced electron energy so now
these reduced components are can then
later be sent to the electron transport
chain which we'll talk about in a future
video to be reoxidized now the oxidation
of these NADH is in these fadh2s is
coupled to the phosphorylation of adp to
make up to make ATP that that process is
called oxidative phosphorylation and
we'll talk more about that later so but
the point is in order to even get to the
transport chain we need to make a bunch
of these first so these things
essentially if they if they are being if
they're if the oxidation of these two
reduced components is being coupled to
the production of ATP then these things
must have some sort of its value right
they have energy value their reduced
forms of energy so how many ATP's is one
NADH molecule worth and how many is one
fadh2 worth well the NADH is worth two
point five ATP and fadh2 is worth one
point five ATP and we'll talk more about
why this is in a later video
why is fadh2 worth less we'll talk more
about that so where does the TCA cycle
even occur it occurs in the
mitochondrial matrix so where is that if
you think about a mitochondria you
probably have seen this sort of diagram
before the matrix is right in there
anything that's bound by this inner
membrane here so this thing that I'm
sort of highlighting here is the inner
membrane if that's the inner
membrane then this must be the outer
membrane so anything bound by the inner
membrane is the matrix or the
mitochondrial matrix anything in between
the two membranes right between the
inner member the inner membrane and the
outer membrane is called the inter
membrane space we'll talk more about
that later but the TCA cycle occurs in
the mitochondrial matrix now is the TCA
cycle of the Krebs cycle of citric acid
cycle is it an aerobic or anaerobic
pathway now this this idea this question
sort of sparked some debate sometimes
and the reason why is as follows
the TCA cycle has actually eight steps
okay now each of those eight steps of
them none of them require oxygen so in
that sense it can be considered an
aerobic right and the reason why is is
none none of the eight steps in the
cycle actually use oxygen so in that
sense it's an error
anaerobic pathway however the pathway
itself the TCA cycle will not run if
there is no oxygen available okay so it
in that sense it is dependent on the
availability of oxygen the cycle itself
will not run if there's no if there's no
oxygen around and why is that
just a brief heads-up oxygen is
basically what a lot it what oxidizes
these energy ages and fadh2s back so if
we create a bunch of nadh and fadh2 is
that means we no longer have any nad
plus S or Fa DS around right so we need
oxygen to reoxidized these things so
that this
can run if we have too much nad ages and
too many fadh2s then this process won't
even occur so in that sense it's an
aerobic process so it really depends on
how the question is worded or how you're
asked but generally generally speaking
the TCA cycle is considered part of
aerobic metabolism it's a little cloud
around aerobic okay but I want you to
understand and be familiar with with
what the debate is all about ok so now
before we can actually get the TCA cycle
to even start running is we need to have
this thing called the pyruvate
dehydrogenase complex occur now what is
this thing so if you recall from
glycolysis we created 3 carbon pyruvates
right we created two pyruvates from one
glucose so the pyruvate dehydrogenase
complex converts pyruvate into acetyl co
a which is basically this thing it can
actually go through the TCA cycle so let
me note that here this is what goes
through the TCA cycle pyruvate camp
pyruvate needs to be converted into
acetyl co a essentially that's this is
called this is likely the activation
step we need to activate pyruvate too
before I can go to the TCA cycle so this
reaction is catalyzed by pyruvate that
is the pyruvate dehydrogenase complex
and the reason why it's called a complex
is actually three different sort of
enzymes that that you know all work
together to get this complex process to
work so what would what happens here
notice that in pyruvate an acetyl co a
we would have this methyl group in this
carbonyl group methyl group carbonyl
group nothing changed there here though
we had a pyruvate we had this carboxyl
group here and I see no group it's gone
and we replaced it with the coenzyme a
so we must have added a co a and lost
the carboxyl group so we added a
coenzyme a and we lost a carbon dioxide
which is how this became a two carbon
molecule right we lost that carbon in
addition this is the
dehydrogenase step right which means we
must think redox reaction which we if we
think redox reaction we think either
NAD+ NADH or FA DF ADH - something
happen well what happened here this
carbon here is bound twice to this
oxygen once to this carbon and then once
to this carbon over here the two bonds
to carbon are the same that bond to this
carbon is the same which mean I said
these two bonds to oxygen the this bond
to carbon are the same but now we have a
bond is two sulfur instead of carbon
sulfur is a little bit more
electronegative than carbon so for
creating more bonds to a more
electronegative atom that is an
oxidation step so we ROCK SCID izing
pyruvate something else must have been
reduced and in this case we actually
reduce an nad plus to make an NADH okay
so we added a coenzyme a and nad plus
and we law we got out an NADH co 2 so in
addition there are actually three more
cofactors that are involved in this and
those three cofactors are TPP TPP lipo 8
and F ad all of these things are
required in order to get this reaction
to run okay so once we have this acetyl
co a this can go to the TCA cycle where
does this reaction actually occur this
occurs also in the mitochondrial matrix
so once we have this acetyl co a in
these in the mitochondrial matrix we can
have the TCA cycle going so that's the
introduction I hope that was helpful and
we'll get into the actual TCA cycle in
the next video thanks for watching